[Music]
hey neil
what's the brightest star in the
nighttime sky
um
are we talking my career here neil
i've been waiting for us to get around
to this
how bright is your star chuck
uh yeah no if if it were me up in the
sky i would just be a dim a dim uh spot
in the milky way it is funny that a
fundamental word in all of hollywood is
derived from my profession in
astrophysics it is the most fundamental
word it is are you a star meaning
are you burning thermonuclear fuel in
your core exactly right
and the walk of fame it's a star
it's a star that's all astro yeah um uh
well it's said that the
from everything i've ever heard that's
the north star that's what people say
well that's the north star it's the you
can always find your way home because
it's the brightest star in the sky just
follow the north star yeah so in my
experience nine out of ten people will
say that
right yeah okay they'll see they'll see
the first bright star after sunset
and then assert that it's the north star
when in
100 of those cases they're looking at a
planet
wouldn't that makes sense because a
planet is right there
plant's right in front of our noses
are right here man
but for me the funny part is they'll
make a wish on the you know star brite
starbrite first star i see tonight right
and then they make a wish and of course
the wishes don't come true because
they're wishing on planets uh
that's why you never knew that
okay i want to explain that to any kid
now just
and then if you're not
if you're not wishing on the on the star
uh and because you know that they're
planets it means you know enough science
not to be wishing on stars that's pretty
cool it all balances out and it's so
funny that you say that it just popped
into my head
what a
uh culturally entrenched
uh sentiment that is wishing on a star
i mean there's songs about it it it
transcends um you know geography and
culture you know you have it and pretty
much and all kinds of writings wishing
on a star that's pretty wild yeah and
that's the and i and i'm honored that my
field supplies this level of cultural
referencing
to do all that we do
so so yeah so the north star is not the
brightest star in the night sky
okay i just want to make that clear okay
now so now here's the thing yeah because
what what is the north star then
what like what is the north star and why
is it
so so let's get in why is it of any
significance if it's not the brightest
star there you go so
we'll get to the brightest star in a
minute so the north star
is the star
in the sky
that's
closest
to where
earth's axis points on the sky
so you have a rotating earth and it's
just sort of rotating right and the axis
is just sort of sitting there as earth
spins around it that axis is pointing to
a spot
in space
okay in the sky
so we say is there a star
near to that spot because then we'd
always be pointing in that direction
right
so the star closest to that spot
is the north star
and the north star has a name
did you know this
um
i want to guess
because the only star that i heard hear
the name of all the time
is the dog star
yeah no that's not
okay well there you go i said it was a
guess
it's not serious it's not serious the
dog star okay yeah yeah yeah the dog
story is serious serious of the dogs are
not the north star so the name of this
star is sensibly polaris
oh
for the pole or the axis polaris polaris
and in fact that was the name i think
of america's first nuclear submarine
polaris
that could launch intercontinental
ballistic missiles um so that they drop
a star on you
you're so american
okay we're about to drop a star on you
with that that produces energy to
vaporize you just the way the centers of
stars do right right it's the same
thermonuclear mechanisms going on so
anyway so it's got a name polaris now
the big dipper
okay
the lip of the big dipper this part
right here okay the lip so there's a
handle and then there's the cup and the
lip is the front edge of that cup right
that points to the north star okay
okay that's how you can always find the
north star
because the big dipper is very obvious
in the northern hemisphere absolutely
okay
so you and then it points and you go
like four
segments up and then boom there it is
okay so the couple of issues with this
first the north star is not exactly
above the pole
okay you can fit
two full moon widths between it
and the exact spot
over
the north pole
gotcha
all right which means if you took a
camera
and a long exposure photo
centered on the north star
the north star will not be pegged in the
middle you'll see it
make a
circle interesting so that is not
exactly above
the north star and the reason why you're
seeing it make a circle is because you
have the long exposure and the earth is
rotating where your camera yes exactly
and so otherwise you just take snapshots
you just get the stars where they are
but if you take a long exposure you get
the stars blurring basically but they
blur with the rotation of the earth
gotcha
and so you'll see that it actually would
trace a circle around the actual north
pole because peop that people are saying
isn't it amazing that we have a star
exactly over the north pole what well
what are the odds well
it's not exactly odds would be zero
that's a bad bet
yeah it's not exactly over the noble not
only that the lip of the big dipper
kind of misses the north star if you did
an exact line it's off so there's a lot
of fakery going on not bad fakery but
just people want the sky to have more
meaning than it actually does
wow
and so they so you say things that are
sort of
partly true just because you feel better
about what it is you're talking about
okay so the north star is kind of like
directionally it's kind of like
getting directions in the hood
it's kind of over there yeah yeah man so
what you want to do
are you going to keep on down there you
wanna keep going and going right right
you're gonna come to uh so it's a car
right but one of the wheels is up on the
crate yeah make it right there
all right you're gonna keep going right
just keep going and going right that's
right directions on the sky from the
stars are exactly like that
so now let me tell you
how
bright the north star is it's not the
brightest but
let me tell you
take a guess
um
i'm going to say it's a b student bright
[Laughter]
okay
it's not
how do you measure brightness in this in
the night sky i really don't even know
that but we have meters that do this
this is science that you don't have to
worry about that we got we got this
all right
and even if you didn't have meters you
could say yep that's brighter than that
and that's dimmer than that yeah we got
this okay we've had this even since
before there were telescopes okay
so
it is not
in the top ten
oh no it is not in the top 20. oh
goodness it is not in the top 30. dad
north star
it is not even
in the top 40. oh my god the north star
is like the united states with respect
to math and science
we say we're number one but we're 47.
the north star is the 49th brightest
star in the night sky oh my gosh it is
completely
uninteresting
it is easily missable right it is does
not call attention to yourself that's
why you need the lip of the big dipper
to find so find it
because you actually need a pointer
because it really isn't remarkable
actually it is not remarkable not
remarkable
wow it kind of reminds me of somebody i
know
that's just
you sound like you should have your own
tv show reminiscence of everyone you
grew up with
stories so yeah so the north star is
just lame i mean it's just embarrassing
and meanwhile people think it's the
brightest star in the night sky
and that's what's weird about it to me i
i just because they've never checked
and so this is the lore overriding
people's curiosity
i wonder how venus feels about that
venus is the most mistaken object for
the north star because it's the
brightest in the night sky the morning
sky venus is sitting around like
just like a man just like a man here i
am just as bright as i can be
every single night i come out is that
what venus sounds like it's at me and
you know what they say oh my god look at
the north star once again a man just
taking
my credit for the hard work that i do
okay
and no that doesn't happen to be a star
in the south pole it's just a big empty
spot there is a star
closer to the south pole than the north
star is to the north pole but it's easy
we don't call that the south star
you can but it's it's it it has a name
it's called sigma octanes
and it's very unassuming and nobody
cares i don't so you know why nobody
cares because its name is sigma octane
don't nobody want to talk about stigma
because there there's a constellation
called octans which is an octet which is
an early version of a sextant and
there's a lot of
navigational instruments among the
constellations of the southern
hemisphere you know why ah because when
europeans uh got to the southern
hemisphere
and decided to map the stars we had
already begun the industrial revolution
and so they weren't thinking centaurs
and greek mythology they were thinking
oh my gosh i'm going to put some badass
equipment here so there's a there's a
there's an architect table
there's a a telescope a microscope
a
sextant and an octant
wow it's all there these are all
constellations of the 88
in the night sky wow so one last thing
about the north star so you can picture
this if you are santa claus looking
straight up what star do you see looking
straight up you see a dead spot
well no yes because we just learned that
but right
but
oh i thought it was a trick question no
that's not true no you look up santa
claus will look up and see the north
star the north star right okay so how
many degrees up is that
from the horizon yeah from the well that
no that should be nothing he's he's
already there no
degrees from the horizon to straight
overhead
for santa claus um let me see because
he's at the top of the world so the
degree's on the horizon no forget the it
doesn't matter just
yes santa claus is on the top of the
world sure but now he wants to know how
high up is the north star for him
above the horizon so how many degrees is
that oh that's um
straight up that's 90 degrees 90 degrees
what is the latitude of the north pole
um
360 degrees
what is the latitude of the north pole
90 degrees 90 degrees
okay i just love no i said that because
i wanted to see that's what i love this
is what i love you being the educator
that you are
because i'll do that and i'm just
waiting for the reaction because if it
were me i'd be like
man what the hell is wrong with you
[Laughter]
hey you do this i gave you a second
chance i gave you something you're like
i said my boy knows better than this i'm
gonna give him a second i'm not gonna
say a damn thing he's gonna fix his own
damn mistake
right but i love it i love it go ahead
the north star is 90 degrees up
when you're at the north pole which is
at a latitude of 90 degrees
that is not a coincidence
okay if santa claus marches south
the north star will get lower and lower
and lower in the sky santa claus gets to
the equator
the north star is on the horizon
the latitude of the equator is zero
the elevation of something on the
horizon is zero
so the elevation in degrees of the north
star above your horizon is your latitude
on earth
oh
because it follows all the way down it
follows all the way down follows all the
way down that looks pretty interesting
yes very interesting and so this was an
important navigational tool that makes
sense for everybody right
right and of course the underground
railroad follow the north star because
if you just walk towards the north star
you'll eventually reach santa claus but
ohio is good enough
yeah you might you might want to keep
going till you get to canada
just in case just in case you never know
all right that's all we got time for
chuck that's north star in a nutshell
all right all right we'll catch you on
the next one
[Music]
you